what did you want bro why are you trying
to facetime me all the time i just
wanted to show i wanted to introduce you
to somebody who was it just a guy oh
then this is why and thank god my face
time no one at 70 says just a guy it's
not good if anybody says yeah if anybody
says if for anybody listening if anybody
says
watch this i
i got a way to make money dude i got a
way that's gonna now listen ron just go
run the other one did you did you bring
that to bring it brian
brian he i see like again i can't
facetime unless stuff yeah wi-fi i was
out with my kids i had the kids all
weekend by myself beast you're not
beastie beasty
my son was my one-year-old was eating
doritos at six in the morning he had
cheese all over his face his grandma was
like what in the [ __ ] was it i don't
know what [ __ ] doritos
i can't get face unless i have wi-fi i
have four missed calls from brian he
goes call me dude with this guy talking
crypto i went nope no i take something
no it wasn't crypto he goes he goes let
me guess we can make a ton of money on
crypto which of course i would never
yeah i i'm the i'm actually
i run the other way when i hear anything
it was something else so what was so
what was intriguing about this
interesting oh yeah it was a more
interesting conversation about something
that i thought was like yeah
tell me after how well now i want to
talk to you
um about the pictures you send me when
i'm
enjoying my i'm on a bike ride when you
sent that
i was working out i was on a bike ride i
was about 12
miles else is into the forest is it an
aggressive pig it was an aggressive now
we can't show it because it will violate
super aggressive rules i was bending
over and i was i was collecting clothes
off the floor
and i was pushing my rump towards my
girl oh
yeah towards my girl brian and yeah
that's i know that's you
well and she the biggest balls i was
showing her yeah bulldogs like like a
like a a full-grown bulldog yeah i got a
dog like a great dog like a great danes
knife they're just like that
dude that's probably why my testosterone
is through the roof hashtag i have
testosterone headaches
you can hang those on the back of a
truck yesterday oh they're nice yes you
gotta set up this i got a set of balls
on me you're like sucking on a set of
balls no i don't i'm sensitive there no
that's suck on them and you've had girls
who go oh uh and you know wow
those aren't for that i know like you
know the whole thing in your mouth there
but yeah that you have to do one at a
time but dick miles in my mouth big they
can bother mine
put the whole thing in my mouth with the
whole thing
when i'm riding my bike that's
aggressive i usually uh put my phone on
silent because i don't want to be you
know doing business like i just tried to
get in a clear year so i work out that's
why i worked out early with you and i
knew you were that way because the
morning for you was your it's my i had
to shatter that dude i don't like you
being 12 miles there yeah i'm in the
middle i'm looking for a rattlesnake
there ding i'm like ding ding ding ding
like holy [ __ ] something might be going
on with tiger or something like that so
i pull over taking my phone i it's
business [ __ ] and i see brian i'm like
oh [ __ ] the picture i wonder what it is
buying an axe and some i click on it
just
yeah ball like you got horrible ball and
i had to send it i only had one person
to send it to that guy and i respect the
guy and you know what my girlfriend
went let me suck them yep that's what
you said yep why do you say that because
i'm gonna double down and i think he's
gonna scare me away and i'm like
okay all right okay and so you double
down back i yelled down and my girl
i was like oh no yeah yeah sucker she
saw me doing something on my phone she
goes you're sending that to brennan and
i go
i am i thought it was cute because she
knows me yeah i am
good more i said good morning
now does she know i was gonna respond
back let me suck them she does yeah
she's like you guys are idiots yeah
y'all different breed
yeah y'all are a different breed now
let's bring the elephant in the room
by elephant i mean cat cat's back she's
back i didn't mean to call you an
elephant
baby cute looking damn i leave for a
little bit you call me an elephant
you're back cat's back baby elephants
are cute they are cute yeah they're
adorable did you get tats
nope
we've had those ties all right yeah that
goosebump shirt is lit yeah thanks be
good for october yeah i'm excited for
october i want to go to uh horror nights
over at university come with us dude
stevie doesn't want to go to anything
like that he says that roller coasters
aren't for him anymore you me and stevie
are the same with that but i'll take
some medicine and go but horror nights
is great and then they're different
because one of them
yeah that's what i was gonna say isn't
that mazes
there's a farm in calabasas that does it
like crazy like a haunted hay oh yeah
right hay rides and there's food trucks
everywhere oh that's fun i want to do it
for halloween and christmas we should go
though i'll talk stevie i'll see you go
if i go please our good friends who uh
it's tiger's best friends their parents
we hang out with all the time they're
scared of that [ __ ] too but we should
talk them in because joanna loves it you
love it i love it those three can just
do whatever yeah let's do it mm-hmm
good to see you back ken you're good
good to have you back fresh face back
have you been to not scary farm uh no
not that one i've been to
the disneyland one when i was a kid and
then disney for kids is great my son
loves it because they do a nightmare
before christmas and did you know this
like the night before christmas like
jack or the girl
i forget her name
sally they'll show up but they do like
special things but the way can tell
where they're gonna be because there's a
line at the [ __ ] gazoo they shine a
certain light with the the with the the
zero the little dog zoo on it so if you
look for that green light that's where
you know they're going to be there in
like 10 minutes oh that's cool some
hardcore falls deep dad [ __ ] yep that is
me and tiger always first in line
i feel bad for those people why do you
have that because they're always like
hey kidding they're you know they're in
full makeup like [ __ ] dude you came here
to be [ __ ] johnny depp some people
take uh [ __ ] halloween very seriously
i remember i went to this really hip
halloween party and i didn't have a
costume dude la halloween parties oh
they're they're on it went dude when i
was single and i'd go these early
halloween parties
you can't come in like a [ __ ] woody
costume from toy story oh dude you gotta
have like oh you got to be late yeah
full makeup and probably zombie you got
to hire the people who do [ __ ]
walking dead i see a guy otherwise you
look like a [ __ ] clown oh i would i
wouldn't go to these [ __ ] people yeah
dude giant white guy i see a giant white
guy in a in a in basically a naked suit
he's got a bad
it's it's a
suit it's like a basically like say you
you put the whole thing on with the
zipper in the back yeah and you you the
color of the out the costume is this
color of your skin
and then he's got yarn a huge yarn bush
and a giant dick a darn giant yarn dick
so he's naked he's wearing a naked suit
and i
he shows up he's really big and i go
and he has balls like yarn balls and i
go this is like this really hit party i
go who are you
and he goes i'm [ __ ] this guy
okay that's it and he just walked around
like a [ __ ] sore thumb in that party
those parties you better come correct
man now
i don't do much on halloween ever though
i don't think i don't think i've ever
really done it actually i went to the
horror nights one year it's big in the
shop
yeah my girl are you into it i i mean i
just don't really care it doesn't like
doesn't like hit me but i don't think
you might if something's like you know
like if if someone invites me somewhere
i'll um
my girls start decorating i mean
probably next week our whole house is my
face
my ex freaks out over that she loves it
yeah my girlfriend goes the same way the
kids go nuts christmas and [ __ ] yeah
halloween forget it she's already but
then they should uh well your girl's
white so i'm sure thanksgiving's big but
dude mexicans thanksgiving they don't
give up that's my favorite
thanksgiving i love thanksgiving oh
what's yours last year yeah it was nice
had a good food huh that was great food
yeah i like you know what's your
favorite holiday
uh i like halloween by halloween really
i think i don't like christmas because
everyone takes too much time off yeah i
don't like christmas because like ca
they take the entire month off yeah
because they have hanukkah and [ __ ] so
that way it's like who takes a month off
let's go
like three days later but go sorry man
when i'm back in the office we'll get on
this like who the [ __ ] takes a month off
it's so annoying that [ __ ] do this i
want to get your perspective on this so
i was at the uh cars and coffee oh
thanks dude i'll take a little ice a
little whiskey uh i was at carson coffee
in malibu and
tiger's obsessed with cars right now so
we go every sunday when i'm home but i
brought his uh friend uh joshua who
they're born and raised in england he's
that little soccer beast he's such a
freak athlete but his dad is born and
raised in england too he just came here
two years ago never been in america wow
so we're looking at cars and jay leno's
there jay leno seinfeld and spike who
was a writer on seinfeld and is best
friends with jerry seinfeld and does uh
they they have car collections together
seinfeld and spike and then i'll see
jerry brings i'm sorry um jay leno
brings his guard that's them in front of
a lot ferrari for god's sake yeah look
at those cute look at that look how cute
they are so a lot bigger is he the same
age that kid same age he's actually
older than tiger
yeah tigers are free anyways
so um
uh
so jay leno's there and we're talking he
pulled up in this old school porsche uh
i forget what it is he's like a 68 or
six dope ass porsche right
and um
he's talking cars and you know he's like
the car guy when it comes to comics and
cars he's he's a gear head like yeah i
know cars
like i can change oil i can change tires
i'm not gonna switch out the engines or
the cams or the [ __ ] headers he can
not seinfeld so much right it's not
seinfeld he's more of a guy jay's the
car
guy yeah like even rogan can't like
switch out headers or like you know like
put a turbo on or something like jake
can do all that himself
he does most of it himself yeah wow he
has like 500 cars in burbank damn yeah
he's one of the greatest collections in
the world wow insane so he's talking
cars with me
and uh
jay leno is yeah i always see him there
we always talk amazing and we talk about
the comedy store and stuff like that and
he goes this is how old school he goes
you go on stage with his tattoos like
it's [ __ ] 20 21 dude
he's like i would never i would never
i'm like later dinosaur anyways
but he's talking cars and he's ball
steam cars he's talking about the valves
and all this stuff and they're walking
away and joshua's dad goes yeah
he has no clue jay leno is he's from
england and he goes that's a [ __ ] car
guy if i've ever heard when i go jay
leno and he goes who i go jay leno is
i've no idea who he is i'm like you've
never heard of jay leno he's no his show
like what's he do i go uh the tonight
show when he was going against like dave
letterman it was like the biggest show
dude i was like and then before he's
even to the stage yeah that might be
because i was like even to this day's
like one of the biggest torn comics like
he has residency in vegas jay leno dude
he's like no i'm like the comedy store
legend jay leno he's like
yeah i was like dude he has like 500
cars he he had spent the dime of his uh
his money yeah he only made the money
they spent off comedy uses yeah but the
money made off uh the tickets show you
won't spend whoa so that's how much
money it makes in combo because yeah
yeah crazy crib and has all those cars
he don't he doesn't touch
how much was he making chin can you look
it up he's probably making like 40
million a year off that yeah 30 million
in the 90s yeah he was so [ __ ] great
his show was so big and i was a jay leno
guy now dave letterman guy 30 million 30
million a year
once took a 50 pay cut
there you go earned 30 million a year in
the 90s see how much [ __ ] money that
is
ufc 266 is here this saturday kids
draftking sportsbook the official sports
beta partner of the ufc has a
heavyweight offer this weekend's fight
with a special odds boost for all the
viewers and listeners for fighters this
week my picks are curtis blades nick
diaz and brian ortega listen all three
have to win you got two dogs there and a
favorite i get it but if you listen
below the belt i give my reasons why i
picked these three just head now to the
app all right find brendan shop's picks
under the odds boost tab doesn't matter
if your new existing customer bet on it
get your boosted odds and ride along
with your boy all new users download the
top rated draftking sportsbook app now
use the promo code fighter when you sign
up bet on my parlay of fighters to win
saturday night for ufc 266 take
advantage of my special odds boost
that's promo code fighter only at
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the ufc
must be 21 or older new jersey
pennsylvania indiana michigan virginia
only restricting supply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 100 gambler or in
virginia 888 532-3500
some things are just bad at home man
some days you don't feel like going to
the gym or maybe your gym makes you wear
a mask some days you want to be home and
get a good workout well that's where my
friends at peloton delivers the workout
experience that you never imagined that
you can get at the crib that's right you
can do everything
from your crib i do it out of my garage
man i do it out of my garage if you're a
peloton member my name is thick prez on
there
thick boy prez i think yeah thick boy
prez that's right prez with a z i'm on
there you guys give me high fives we can
join the workout together hashtag thick
boy bike clubs on there as well they
have curated music just for you whatever
you like man hip hop country peloton has
the right music to keep you entertained
motivated all year long all right
when you purchase belt on bike you get
access to live classes thousands on
demand classes which is what i do they
have 20 minute classes 30 minute 45
minute we got you covered man with
pelton bike there's nothing like working
out at home learn more at onepelton.com
new members can try peloton classes for
free for 30 days at onepelton.com app
terms apply that's onepelton.com
n dot o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
so i was talking him and he and he's
like he's a good comic i'm like you [ __ ]
jay leno and i kept going jay leno he
goes mate i don't know who he [ __ ] is
i'm like uh so he's trying to explain
i'm like well
i was you know joe rogan he's like kind
of i'm like well he doesn't know no
so is he a superstar soccer player or
not superstar good but really good good
but professional though on a high level
yeah in in england yeah yeah now he
comes here and does like computer stuff
he he's a beast super super sure but
while i was telling i was like
and tell me if this comes comparison
makes sense i was saying jay leno in
like the the 80s the 70s and 80s was
like what joe rogan was the comedy store
like he was the guy like people came to
see jay leno like when he moved
everybody moved the way general jay leno
did like he stuck up with comedians he
was the guy who was like dude he was the
only guy mitzi didn't give [ __ ] that
could play at the improv and the store
he's like now i'm going where i get up
i'm not i'm not loyal this place i go
where when they did the the strikes yeah
he was part of that strike yeah he was
the striker he was the guy that was out
there like helping he got he actually
got yeah he got hit by a car didn't he
yeah yeah yeah he was the guy and he's
like what i'm like yeah dude and then i
was telling him i was like he's
interesting because he told me if you do
this today talking to chin about the sun
below the belt
he's a guy who doesn't believe in uh
adding material like he believes in
getting your hours set together he's had
the same set for 30 40 years and he
doesn't shoot any specials when you see
him you you know what you're going to
get it's the hits because he's like
jayla and i heard jay leno say this on i
think he said it to kevin hartman kevin
hart show he goes i don't get why comics
come up with new [ __ ] he goes if you go
see a band
you don't want to hear their new stuff
you want to hear their classics you want
to hear what they've been doing he's
like so i don't write any stuff
and uh the joshua's dad was like could
well why don't you do that i'm like i
don't think you can do that today's
world like because it's like if there's
the material not only not only that and
the concept like if you're a thinking
moving living breathing artist not to be
use that word but if you're in the
business of self-expression you go
through different things in your life
and things change and things matter to
you and worry you and scare you and
enjoy and excite can you imagine doing
the same hour you did that you shot in
tally hall that's why no i would i would
throw that away
never i i'm oh by the time i shop for
showtime or the stuff i'm doing now by
the time i shoot that i'm exhausted at
that material i'm dying i'm like i can't
wait to [ __ ] he's a guy who's so
conservative
i mean well all due respect that's the
reason that he's he might be a legend
because he's he's always worked and been
consistent and been there but he's more
of a legend for the tonight show
i don't think any of us have ever i can
tell you this spoken about jay leno's
amazing comedy his stance coming up he
was a beast but then now we get to a
certain point when he's coming up i've
watched his stuff he was he was good he
was really like my dad my dad went
because you know he does sets every
night or literally
magic club yeah
is that meant is that where you're at
but just like you know you have to clean
material there yeah yeah like that yeah
i'm sure you'd do great there jay would
you do a set and uh
then they were like oh wait can you send
us a ten minute clip no problem i'll
come down send them a clip like don't
bother coming down we're literally only
clean i'm like oh that's yeah yeah
that's not what i do man yeah
jay leno and then i'm over here jay's
was very safe very mainstream very
commercial and very a digestible to
america to moral majority to middle
middle america you know and he's he's
safe part of what it was yeah but he's
also like his his fan base was so you
put him in the lineups we used to do you
you put him in the middle of that lineup
that we used to have have you heard
they're all i mean nobody knew who he
was have you have you gone back and
heard like some of david letterman's
stuff from the comedy store
i mean he had eaten alive today i mean
well well i always say this that so so
david letterman became a talk show host
because david letterman was never
he's not competing with the great comics
he didn't like to come you know that
david didn't like do comedy he was
really good with words and he spoke
really well and his vocabulary was the
beast yeah and he was very smart but he
didn't like doing stand-up he had at the
end of the day he looked at that you
know he quit because of jay leno because
jay leno's work ethic was insane insane
and he was like oh i'm not gonna i'm not
willing to do all this work that jay is
he's like so i'm out he was the
anti-comic in a way like jalen was very
snarky and very like indiana and very
like well we gotta but it wasn't that
jay leno i mean i'm sorry uh david
letterman david letterman wasn't gonna
kill you with this comedy but he'll tell
you before yeah he'll tell you that and
and again that's what i always say is
that you know part of being a comic
today is with social media you have to
keep reinventing yourself it's really
[ __ ] hard to stay relevant oh if you
take a year off you're out of the room
six months off people stop thinking
about you so we're in a very different
position there's too much there's too
much we're in a third we're we're
competing with with tick tock we're
competing with the entire internet
that's why saying joshua's dad i'm like
you i was like you especially if you're
just starting out like you kind of have
a following you can just regurgitate the
same material because they're looking at
like andrew schultz and they're looking
at tim dillon and they're looking at
changing chris stefano looking at these
monsters like
schultz put out an hour of just the
crowd work like and then he he's come
out with an hour you know
once he puts it out for a month let's
start all over again it's not like you
can do that one set and hold on to it i
mean where are you going to do that i
mean i got you know if you but the
yeah now now i mean the tv show i did at
goldbergs was a hit yeah it was abc's
number one comment and how many people
watched a big deal right how many people
would watch that you think we got
literally
and this is a good maybe a million
now it was on a really good night it was
about five to six million that's a lot
for today's age can i just give you and
give you perspective so when i did
inside schwarz
when i did inside schwartz
your balls are you know your balls are
your downfall yeah
because they just hang there because
they're such a you could just grab them
like a lion fighting [ __ ]
ship
i know but they're so elastic though
i could turn around you can rub my balls
suck them oh god
no because i could turn around as you
had i turn around and the skin would
wrap around my head yeah you're good
yeah you could have they always been
like that bro oh no you get older and
they just no you
but the thing is about
i saw it the other day it was nice
you're still you're still doing it man
still got it going on yeah with the old
piece yeah he always inspects what what
i'm doing and then i'll slap it dude
turn around
keep your head keep your hands to
yourself you know what i'm saying put
that dick in my face i'll slap it
he went like this
that wet ass dick just and i went like i
go sorry he's been bad
put it back that soft hard get him back
in there yep yes i slap it around it's a
hot day sometimes i just look at him and
i go he look at that he's doing that
wait so when did that when did those
balls go back to jay leno i think
because with the comics now and putting
out fresh material and they'll drop you
know a five-minute cut out and on their
instagram something like that like the
audience is conditioned different so if
you came out and let's say you were like
hey guys i'm just gonna continue to do
the hour i've been doing the past six
years you're dead you you have one list
you're not going to sell tickets you're
not gonna sell tickets i don't think you
can the audience is just they've adapted
no and you're competing with everything
comedy's so different now and i also
don't understand why jay leonard would
do comedy if he does the same song over
there
but what's this yeah melissa as you and
i are broke but listen to jay leno and
[ __ ] uh
jerry seinfeld
seinfeld same thing he goes i don't get
why you guys do new material
monsters now they both had the huge
built-in audience obviously seinfeld
when seinfeld was they got away with
seinfeld got special though the comedy's
so different but no he he did a special
then he regurgitated the same special he
just he just did it again really yeah oh
dude that's so weird because remember
like you with with the younger guys like
yourselves
you guys are the beneficiaries of
podcasting and social media when i for
the most of my career and everyone's
going to be on tv
on tv yeah if you weren't on tv you just
you had to rely on
local media and they the club would kind
of push you it was impossible to make
money if you made if you made it as a
comic if you made five grand for the
weekend
you know you're doing well that's huge
but it wasn't money but those old school
days are still around it's like you know
i'm in san antonio and we've sold a [ __ ]
ton of tickets like oh can you do this
spurs only podcast and i told my brother
like ask him how many listeners gets
like we get like 800 like 800 000 like
no no like 800 people like well no
i can't do that yeah no it doesn't make
sense it's waste my time no no that's
exactly right
what is the reach because you don't have
time for it no it's just a different
animal you don't have time for other
[ __ ] distinction though right that
english guy had no clue
i'm not trying to explain that to him
but then i went to uh
my son's
upper class at a football game on friday
they invited all the kindergarten kids
there and their parents so i brought
tiger the football game so i'll see
tiger to understand the rules that guy
from england sure is like don't know the
rules so spent the entire game
explaining the rules how was your
football level football uh it was good
the team they played was like like three
in the state i think uh our team's like
seven so it's good just good good
there's one like super stud yeah and in
the first series oh that team's gonna
kick this team's ass really you could
just tell oh yeah
joshua's dad was like how do you know
i'm like just dude i'm telling you man
they don't
wow they have their [ __ ] together and
they have one superstars you know like
essie he's this big receiver i'm like
they're just gonna throw it to that
dominant kid yeah he's gonna score all
the touchdowns just taller
like he should yeah he can play college
right now you're not gonna stop that
[ __ ] guy
it's fun though i haven't been a high
school football game since i played yeah
but if you're after the first quarter if
your kids not playing who gives
checked out huh oh dude especially if
you were scared i'm scared
my kids are not playing i don't give a
[ __ ] about these other kids now now as a
football player do you want tiger to
play football oh yeah i'd love to play
football just but that was the apparent
like all the parents were talking like i
don't know like what age do you start
them would you let them play football i
said
you know that and they're like have you
seen that movie concussion i've seen the
movie concussion think about the
millions and millions of kids that play
every year millions and millions of kids
a lot out of them enough yeah
they like all the less football players
in my opinion and correct me if i'm
wrong of any other athlete football
players are the most socially
intelligent
because they're in locker rooms yeah and
it's a team sport but if you want to
talk about football like if you were to
hire somebody who
was a great like great sales person or
just you wanted
a great sense of humor usually i mean
i'm always surprised
and a lot of the stars the big programs
have marketing training like they they
give you like i see you we had training
on how to conduct an interview how to
respond to it like oh yeah really yeah
there's marketing don't quite if you get
into like real estate and do really good
with that too yeah yeah yeah a lot of
them do but i was telling those parents
i'm they're talking about the movie
concussion i'm like you got to realize
think of all the millions of kids that
play football every year and then how
many cases ct do we see i was like this
was like what sport what sport do you
want to talk about alexa i'm like you're
into soccer kids in soccer they get i
mean if you they get concussed to head
in the ball so if you're worried about
all that stuff you're not gonna let them
do [ __ ] man like you you're a couple of
things you're gonna break some eggs to
make an omelette yeah a couple things
like when you look at the metadata like
somebody was whatever you want to say
about the vaccine and whatever you want
to say about like fillings like we they
started talking about how you got i
remember this they were talking about
how when you have steel fillings like
i've got is in the 40s yeah in the fight
they used to get steel fillings the
mercury goes to your brain and all that
i said to my my dentist i go i got these
steel fillings and he said yeah i know i
go the the mercury and he said
okay here's the problem with all that we
have almost a billion people in the
world with steel fillings and if you
look at some people gonna have adverse
reactions yeah with the vaccine if you
look somebody with any friends of
statistician he's not a statistician but
his job is he looks at data and he goes
uh
and his wife was very anti-fact she's
kind of very into herbology and all that
and he said okay that's cool um
but by the way
just look at the two or three billion
people that have already gotten the
vaccine
how many people are having adversaries
right you can't use personal stories and
it's the same thing as like as like i
sat in the room one time and i saw i saw
i found out who
was a movie star and who wasn't and what
i mean by that was
who can get a movie made and get money
for a movie versus who doesn't and
whatever you think whoever you think can
you'd be so surprised how small that
group is it's like it goes back to jay
leno being famous here but not
necessarily when when you have there are
very few people that are internationally
recognized
i still like that stuff like the emmys
and the oscars so i was watching last
night and like even the vmas it's the
low so it was on ten different
mainstream channels ten different lowest
ratings of all time i think they the
emmys no they
are vmas which were used to be huge yeah
i think they said 600 000 people
watching
no those are fun kid numbers dude
i mean listener and audio but wow kid
numbers get the [ __ ] out of it all the
promotion all the hacks said bieber just
think like who's watching tv do nobody
and especially that young audience who's
watching like bieber they're not they
have network tv they don't care my
friends my friends got an hour uh drama
on tv on cbs or something and i was like
oh and it comes out at a certain time
and i was like and he's like yeah
nobody's watching well
they they sure aren't well think about
like our boy uh
shane gillis releases special just
reached over a million views 1.1 if you
really sat on say comedy central or tnt
or where the hbo or showtime yeah but
there's tv shows that do good still
on like netflix yeah i guess yeah yeah
like as far as different like one that
comes like
like wednesday night that yeah like cbs
yeah like i can't and like people are
busier than ever now and they have their
phones so we were talking about i'm
gonna i'm gonna release yeah i'll try to
release like a half of 30 minutes on on
youtube that's what i told you you know
yeah because i'm already releasing clips
you know it's just better no do it do a
30 and put on youtube yeah let me help
with the marketing and all that all
right that'd be good yeah
yeah but shane gillis just hit a million
like yeah if he really said it's like
whoever bought like netflix or hbo or
showtime or comedy central that ain't
hitting a million you don't even know
anyway right they don't even tell you
netflix doesn't tell you anything
nothing and then also it's up to your
discretion like
you know he has some stuff on there i
don't think any network is going to let
it fly but him release on his own like
seems like it's the way to go right now
100 when before like i was telling them
that we just here last week it's like
before it's like if you release on
youtube it's kind of like damn everybody
turns you down and he did say that no
one's gonna pick this up i'm like yeah
but those days are done man yeah like
that's the
direct access to your fans that's right
and then your fans
you know copy it and send it to you you
gotta check this bit out yeah easy easy
to send just tell it like i can't win
that that's what i can't send an out
that's if you want to sell tickets
that's what you want i'm gonna send my
picture of my balls out like that oh
that'd be the cover of that'll be the
thumbnail for my special just that
billion views just and it's called my
special is going to be called older old
oh hashtag old and low yeah oldie yeah
oh goldies but goodies yup yup you know
going on online is crazy man a lot of
you go oh i know most you're probably
thinking why don't you just go incognito
mode let me tell you something right now
incognito mode doesn't hide your
activity it doesn't matter what mode you
use or how many times you clear your
browsing history your internet service
provider can still see every single
website you've ever visited each sorry
that's why even when i'm at home i never
go online without using
expressvpn it doesn't matter who your
inner internet service provider is isps
in the us can legally sell your
information to ad companies not cool
expressvpn is an app that reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
servers so your isp can see the sites
you visit they can't see it they cannot
see it they can't if you don't use this
man expressvpn
also helps keep your information secure
by encrypting 100 of your data with the
most powerful encryption available all
right expressvpn is available on all
your devices phones computers even your
smart tv so there's no excuse for you
not to be doing it man protect your
online activity today with the vpn rated
number one by cnet visit my exclusive
link expressvpn.com
fighter you can get an extra three
months free on a one year package that's
express e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p
and dot-com fighter expressvpn.com
fighter to learn more well that was a
serious picture man i did not expect
that it's a lot i'll call it just
elastic
oh
yeah
rubber knuckles and your balls are red
dude they look inflamed they're just
yeah why are they probably
who the [ __ ] knows what i do with that
when did you notice that drop i dragged
him around what are you i've always had
nuts on you though yeah i got nuts on me
what did you notice that's right they're
tight they're tight
what's amazing about oh
the warm showers the kid still wakes up
with a boner a lot of times that's that
means my testosterone at 54. [ __ ]
stupid that's usually a good sign that's
hilarious by the way that that happens
to me shane or uh chin we need to check
out your testosterone man what's up
you're falling apart over there you look
tired it's just this damn thing
that's why my voice started to change
because you're singing i don't think
you're yelling yeah you were singing you
sing a lot
you sing a lot of songs on saturday i
know but it was fine afterwards it's hit
like this morning it takes like two days
i'm the same like if you notice when i
come off the road monday i'm blown about
my voice is all weird yeah oh okay well
you're good yeah and i want you to start
you're sitting down too much i want you
to start moving i do move no you don't
listen to me
i do this how was the concert this
weekend it was a lot of fun our boys
showed up phoenix yeah was it phoenix
and you went yeah do you see some old
friends
uh no i mean i i i don't
i don't tell people when i'm going to
phoenix all right chappelle's chapelle
found reading and chappelle's reading a
lot and just watch i'm telling you watch
him in a year
that's all
chappelle sent me a clip of you doing a
cover for jelly roll
and then i sent the jelly roll he's like
i love this send it to me so i can post
it what a great guy i send it to you so
cool but it came through two small
scissors oh
i sent it again so hopefully you can
post them it's all good no it was it was
beautiful like i mean
it was like cool hearing you live
because i've like seen your video clips
for like you know but like that live
sound
i mean you sound just like [ __ ]
chickens
dude when they did the hannah baron song
i was like oh chin sounds the exact same
it's kind of just like the just like the
very sweet was it where was it actually
it's the place called the rebel rebel
lounge chappelle knows a lot about it
yeah yeah it's the spot i would always
go to your neck is still any better or
not it's actually worse but i luckily i
have an appointment i got to fly around
and [ __ ] that can't help yeah i'm sure
it does not i'm also seeing on stage
yeah he didn't he didn't do much
movement on stage but i said but but it
was good
you still can't you can't do that no
yeah i saw the video chin gets like
doesn't
goes
yeah yeah
he points out people have you had a
massage i did that's the first thing i
did i got a deep tissue massage and i
think that made it a little bit worse
and it inflamed itself yeah yeah
sometimes
i can hear i can hear it in your voice
now yeah i think that's just from yeah
you sang a lot i hope it's from singing
yeah
you sounded really really good thank you
dude yeah
how did little brows do
he's he's meant for the stage yeah
he really is he's better on stage i
don't know what this is oh it's brian
kelleher jesus christ
[Music]
[Music]
thank you man
[Music]
[Applause]
right
what little brows do when you sing this
song
uh i mean he's new to rapping like that
and that's a very good he moves a lot
yeah he moves a lot so like he he goes
back there i think chen does like two
yeah
what's his name
and then we need a rap name for him and
everybody's called little these days
call him little brown little brows
he's not little no he's not he's
athletic looking he's a good looking kid
he's an attic man
i know he has a crazy story crazy good
looking guy sweet guy always physically
fit super hard-working great dad too
yeah great dance dad really great
he's not great he's a 10 year old or
something like
recently yeah because he announced it on
stage i think he just had yeah yeah a
few weeks ago maybe why don't you
what would i have to pay you to open for
me in my my shows just chin [ __ ]
opens up well just five thousand dollars
fifty five thousand fifty fifty five
hundred all right
of course shin comes on sings come down
to colorado
um
he uh yeah little brows though he so he
we had a white rap contest on king this
thing and he would just dominate like
destroy absolutely destroy and he got a
following from that and then released
the all cats album he's gonna do all
just hit a million streams yeah mm-hmm
the whole king the sting album with him
and like some other people on there wow
and it hit a million
goddamn songs about cats songs about me
songs about i know they're like fun
songs but they're actually good songs
yeah
see one million streams right there oh
wait there's a good go to that picture
that's not that one
no that's not a couch
yeah that's pretty cool yeah nirvana
played there that's how og that that
place is really yeah
did you get on stage and do anything i
just
i don't know what to do i was hoping it
was like he's like come on i'm not gonna
dude
it's too low oh there's no yeah the roof
is too low
there's no way
i know because brows was like go do
backflip i said look at that roof
that's true chin and brows no it was
good it was it was cool to watch you
guys man it was you know and
fans were pretty stoked on them thanks
man thanks for coming out too that's
awesome
it was it was awkward and then uh he had
me come up on stage for he did he closed
with your song yeah which one
yeah
we always say how we appreciate brendan
schaub because
he basically started this whole thing
yeah yeah yeah it gives you a shout out
shows you love yup it's pretty dope it
was good yeah brows is killing it it's
only a lot of time for you below yeah
he's gonna be yeah
and he's yeah and he's going out and
doing these shows and pushing his stuff
out there man
it's actually yeah it's really cool
then he'll be at the emmys and vmas and
that'd be so cool if you guys actually
makes it there one day the vmas yeah
something like that it's like 7000
people watch yeah that'd be amazing but
it'll be good for him to be on it yeah
hell yeah hey man come on they're on the
vmas don't a big deal
don't piss on their future
he's not pissing on it
but if you're at the vmas that means
you're crushing it yeah if you're there
you're crushing that no limit oh man
yeah
big boy you got to dream big i might get
into music now what would my rap name be
oh you gave him a name before right
right
something else no rings
there's something before rings i forgot
what it was
first album could be called the ball
dropper you know what i'm saying
no do that far right song you did
your dunk you gotta walk something sam
was like what are those
you didn't
[ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up you shut the
[ __ ] up
i didn't need to dude dude it was so
good right
thanks thanks dude the drums and bass
and the guitar all that stuff yeah he
did really good
yeah i wrote that yeah i know he didn't
play it but it was like
it was good sounded good dan crenshaw's
like yes
[ __ ] get them
hey guys uh colorado uh comedy works uh
denver this weekend you're in denver
this weekend i'm there next weekend man
i bet my mom would go to both shows she
will go to yours mama's vaccinate too
can't wait to see mom and and and i'll
be vaccinated dude i'll be first in line
and get vaccinated right nobody's a
little worried about so not she is oh
yeah
hopefully invite not being your mom
we'll see
we'll see we'll see we'll see if they
want to come
they always come to my show i know
yeah i'm sure they're vaccinated or have
to show proof of uh
whatever vaccination yeah why uh why
they call it nubby
ah in england you always have like my
nickname they always call me burn babs
it's just like they're lingo yeah
everyone has nicknames yeah
and jay was jager jj yep everyone see
what we got here oh what we got
my mom's name is debbie liu
okay so uh usain bolt recently
released a statement saying that his
advice to shikari richardson is that she
needs to talk less and train harder he's
correct on this because she keeps losing
and she came out recently and said that
she's not going to take his advice
because he didn't reach out to her
personally saying that he's giving her
advice online but he never reached out
to her yeah but i'm sure he did an
interview and was yeah
she needs to win like shut up and win
train harder yeah
that's but again best thing ever
happened to her
because she's not nowhere near the
fastest girl in the world
ninth place she's interesting but
everybody know about her hold on and i
think when i she's gonna learn how to
control the emotion and do it she's
gonna train hard huh
i hope she listens she ain't listening
to most people train more i think most
people are sick of her [ __ ] at this
point because she's not winning yeah she
would have gotten these other races
people like are you go girl but now oh
you're more clicks than you say
how stupid of a tweet is that yeah
who's saying
he's not looking for clowns
no he's doing an interview because he's
the greatest sprinter of all time yeah
okay shakari richardson he's like all
right yeah she just needs to [ __ ] win
man
what have you got jen yeah yeah
so last week little baby went online and
he posted a photo of him with the watch
that he had and he was flexing on the
gram saying that he had an exclusive
40th anniversary watched by patel
philippe yeah
and it turns out that it was fake a lot
of people zoomed in on his watch because
a few people who were really into
watches wanted to see what it looked
like and they noticed that there were
some discrepancies in like the sizing of
the chain links and different things
like that and so
he little baby didn't know that it was
fake he then said that he bought it from
a reseller that he works with very
closely that sells him a lot of his
jewelry and that reseller
apologized saying that oh i should have
personally oh this is back to
and he paid four hundred thousand for it
four hundred thousand because he
couldn't get on the exclusiveness of the
actual brand got it that's why he went
through a reseller
now um
for a watch oh my gosh and uh
little babies big especially with the
young uh yeah he's huge so huge now you
and i know about this gotta make 800
000. okay now so you gotta make 800
grand i don't give a [ __ ] who you are
that's a lot of money it's a lot of
money that's a lot of money we know
somebody we know some people with money
and they don't you're gonna spend that
much money it was like i saw this boxer
who was famous kind of famous but he had
a blue phantom rolls royce how much are
those [ __ ] 500. yeah so he had to make a
million dollars the first thing he did
was a million dollars when bought a
rolls royce
this kind of stuff is to me is so hard
to understand yeah when you're walking
around and you've got a million dollars
of jewelry on your body that you know if
you tried to resell you would you would
get a hundred grand for not the fatigue
if it's real watches
what about the change though right
chains are a bad idea because it's all
custom yes
chains rings and stuff they'll sell it
to you too they'll let you go bro the
reason they're the custom jewelry in
nightmares oh yeah i hear you do those
uh do do your watch up or something like
that but that like
ruins
like if he just leaves the petite
philippe alone and the other stuff yeah
oh yeah especially rolex there's a huge
industry in that yeah so it is a good
yeah so watches really hold there
he's not doing that no no he bought a
fake one well there you go that that
stuff to me is
nuts
and you paid 400 000. like i get that
you love jewelry but bro yeah
you got so much money on your hands and
that that
you it's it's a depreciating asset yeah
let's just put it that way
it might be a better idea to
spend your money on some other stuff how
much money do you have in the bank
you know brian yeah he's huge but it's
yeah it's tough man it says 5 million in
the bank there you go
now that's not a lot of money man it's
not when you're spending
400 grand on a watch that's going to
last you three months
what are you driving but if you have 5
million in the bank and you spent
basically damn near 800 grand on a watch
that's
you know oh i i had a long conversation
with a guy really like he was uh about
20 years ago
let's just put it that way he's a
wu-tang club yeah and
he was telling me about how much money
he was spending
and then he told me
i said how many kids do you have
and he goes
he goes i live the lifestyle now i like
this dude talented smart guy but he
meaning he has a lot of kids because you
wanna yeah he went like that i got him
he goes i got so much all over he goes
like that
that's gonna take all your money no way
to go bankrupt and then then he was
talking about having a cut back on you
know what he was
but the
people set themselves up to a point
where just to maintain what you have is
[ __ ] speech
is a million dollars a year
more but also chin if you look at a
little baby's background let's look if
you went to his uh
so let's just
little baby was born in atlanta in 1994
raised by a single mother he didn't take
to school dropped out in ninth grade so
ninth grade education after he was
released from jail in 2017 for dealing
drugs being a full-time rapper the rest
is history now he has an impressive 5
million in the bank so you realize from
his perspective where he comes from
they're not he's probably like i'm yeah
everybody has to and i i could have used
the people around me i'm terrible with
money so i can talk you know like
financial fitness is really important
now i have a brother-in-law and a dad
and a grandfather who are like hey
[ __ ] you are an idiot with money and
i am i don't pay attention i don't think
about it but
i always feel kind of like in a bit of
an affinity because if i didn't have
that guidance i'd be right there
probably yeah most people so yeah so so
unless you've been taught like how money
works you don't know you just like [ __ ]
this man i'll make more but also if
someone you feel guilty
if also if someone who doesn't come from
his background is like hey dude you
might have another three years doing
this and then who knows man you got to
come up with hit after hit it's
exhausting let's say you have an off
year what are you going to do you ever
think about that i heard you same thing
with the nfl like it's like did you know
like right you signed this big contract
you might have another six years in the
way you're living for a long time that's
what i'm saying like if you're a star
player it's like after six years what
are you gonna do dude
like this money's like and then in the
real world you trying to figure out how
to maintain this lifestyle it's going to
be a nightmare no one really thinks like
life so after they retire is there a
small percentage of like that really
that have their
you know funds really well it's a small
percentage for sure yeah but like even
elon musk said i heard him saying um i
suffer from something that a lot of
people suffer from even i suffer from
something called wishful thinking
which would be
not looking at the reality and
kind of just you know how people go it
is what it is or it'll work itself out
30 billion of course but even so like
even he said i have to always remind
myself not to say
things like that because what happens is
you kind of leave it to the universe as
well as to actually
what's real which isn't really actually
yeah yeah yeah
money's that way you look at real
numbers what's it cost you to make that
yeah yeah you know
what else you got jen
yeah for that jeweler though that is
crazy so
there is a video of a mother of a middle
school child in austin texas at a
district meeting the meeting was for
parents to voice their concerns about
the coven mandates but this woman
chose to speak about something else and
there is i believe a two-minute
clip of her complaining that her son had
come home from school with the book and
the book then has a line about
having sex with a woman
in her butt
essentially a book yeah there's like a
raunchy book that was in this middle
school library that her son had checked
out they were reading it and she's the
mother the mom guys
yeah and so the school district had to
take the books away
marge stone
all right well i'm just thankful that
y'all don't have the ability to um make
a mask mandate and tonight i was going
to talk about the need for a second high
school but i was sidetracked by
for the boys [ __ ] or the idea of [ __ ]
or the idea of idea of [ __ ] a mexican
is a mexican is a mexican
take her out back we boys figured then
hand on the titties put it in her coin
box put it in her cornhole grab a hold
of that braid rub that calico you can
find that on page 39
of the book called out of darkness which
you can find at hudson bend middle
school and bee cave middle jesus christ
all right not gonna lie i had to google
corn hole because i have the game in the
back of my yard
[Music]
for anus the term came into the use in
the 1910s in the night the united states
is first foreign
i love america
only america
why do they have that book there though
yeah i do not want my children to learn
about anal sex
in middle school i have never had anal
sex i don't want to have anal they're
all faced
[Music]
i want you to start
focusing
though
what was this go what was this the thing
about child pornography or they were
there was pornography
what was this child pornography what was
this there was a the mayor of the town
said all of you
can either get brought up on charges or
resign immediately did you see this what
yeah
and there's something about this
school board
well let's type this in because it was
[ __ ] crazy i know i know yeah
oh man that's cool yeah watch this
yeah this is the one watch this
earl
members of the board my name is craig
schubert i'm the mayor of this city
has come to my attention oh wow
your educators
are distributing essentially what is
child pornography
in the classroom
i've spoken to a judge this evening
she's already confirmed that she said
the assignment also has students to
pretend they were serial killers and
describe the taste of bear
from this board of education
or you will be charged
thank you
oh [ __ ] oh damn everyone's in support of
it
so
so what what happened what was that what
was the art i don't know scroll we'll
scroll down dude
now what the [ __ ] are they thinking
mayor of hudson i was a conversation
entire board of educated after high
school seniors signed a controversial
book with ryan simons to ask them to
describe sexual experiences to pretend
they were a serial killer and describe
taste of bear
um he said all this already it's not
clear what the charge burns could face
the board's presence said wednesday that
no members dedicated any intention
resign
what the [ __ ] the assignment that
sparked the mayor's strong reaction was
a book 64 642 things to write about
okay
this was seniors taking a credit college
credit course at hudson high school the
book contains prompts such as write a
sermon from a beloved preacher who has
been caught in sexual scandal describe
your favorite part of a man's body using
only verbs choose how you will die right
an x-ray disney scenario jesus christ
man i mean this is interesting
uh but wow
i would be furious other prompts but
these are 18 year olds other prompts ask
students to write a sex scene you
wouldn't show your mom and then rewrite
the sex scene for from above on into
one that you'd let your mom read
interesting it also asks students to
drink a beer and write about the taste
and list what television shows would be
on their dvr okay
if there was
these are these are classic provocative
uh fiction writing exercises
which are you know but where's the child
pornography thing
i think he was going because they were
talking about like he asked them to
write about a sexual experience they had
and he probably
you know connected that with being child
pornography but are they 18 what it
seems what it seems like high school
seniors
senior 18 or is it seven between 17 17
and 18. so i'm not as worried about that
um i don't know
it's a little i thought it was a middle
school thing this is these are seniors
it's classic it's it's to be expected if
you're going to do that this is america
you're going to have pushback and you're
going to have people like but also i
don't see what it's just being creative
he's a little dicey it's dicey it's nice
there's a million other things you
should write about to get college credit
yeah but that's that gets kids writing
right that's the other thing when you're
teaching that might be a way to get kids
to really like in psychology we had to
write like our own obituary or something
like that yeah they did that to them
yeah it was it was a dude it was
creative writing you were crying yeah
but creative writing classes will say
write describe a barn the side of a barn
from the from the perspective of a man
who just lost his son in the war but you
can't use the words war son or oh you
know
just like it gets you exercise yeah yeah
yeah yeah so
a little weird a little out there i
think they should lose their job a
little weird yeah what else you got jen
it's interesting
here we go okay the anal book is just
out of control
people aren't like let me read every
book you know you just you order books
in bulk right and so all of a sudden you
get this book yeah
what's this gin okay so a mother in
oklahoma was going to the grocery store
and she needed to get pizza rolls from
the freezer aisle when she reached in to
get the pizza rolls she noticed that
there's something mushy on the other
side so she picked up the bag flipped it
over and started screaming when she
realized that she had touched human [ __ ]
and this guy [ __ ] and then put it in and
so she screamed so loud started
complaining that everybody at the
grocery store they looked through their
cctv and they have this photo of a man
who had allegedly
taken a [ __ ] in the freezer 2021 why is
that
him that's her yeah
yeah
yeah that's a good one
she took the phone
out but she took a photo of her why
would he put in the freezer
right i don't know how cause of that
picture because people are still into
that
because it's like i told you like my
body panic
[ __ ] was like yeah
the gym i worked out in i told you in
marina del rey a dude would come in they
knew he was and you'd be taking a shower
and then you'd be like what the [ __ ] and
he'd be taking a shower and then
he'd take his [ __ ] and leave it in the
corner and so what would happen is the
next guy get in take a shower and they'd
be like what and there was a giant [ __ ]
there now they knew who it was they just
couldn't prove it so then the manager
starts following the guy around and
every and he the guy never [ __ ] and then
one day the manager was the desk he was
busy and he just saw the guy like this
and the guy goes
the guy looks at him
he goes
as he leans he just turns
and he goes
have a nice
and my my other buddy who's a trainer
there still laughs when he tells the
story like he still loses his [ __ ]
bandit the guy was a [ __ ] bandit
sometimes you get [ __ ] he gets off on
them
there are people that break into houses
and jerk off in the closet you know
because it turns them on and they leave
there's all kinds they don't even take
anything he's just running i told you my
friend i think my buddy who i was very
close to was probably that guy i hate
this oh wow but we were at a party and
he decided he didn't like the way the
woman was treating the case and he went
in he goes guard the closet like what
are you going to do he just guard the
closet he took a giant [ __ ] oh snake
skin oh wow and then she somehow called
me and said
what
you know something about this and i said
i don't know
jesus oh my god who shits on his boots
well i'm about to pee my pants go for it
um this is howard stern going off on joe
rogan what because of the well he says
anti-vax views but
he just doesn't like the way that joe
rogan talks about the vaccine
this is the only time howard turns been
relevant in the past 10 years so
congrats that you're back in the
headlines
uh but this sounds stupid but this how
stupid howard stern is with his stuff he
thinks by getting vaccinated that you're
it's a cure like it like it it stops
coving he's like get back saying we can
stop this thing
it it it will subdue
the
if you do get it but it doesn't cure
[ __ ] covet dum-dum so here's i heard
joe rogan saying what are you busting my
balls for i took horse dewormer and a
doctor gave it to me he said well a
doctor would also give you a vaccination
so why take horse dewormer the shock
jock who supports mandatory vaccination
it also has much for all the [ __ ]
in our country won't get vaccinations
now before i go on you you'll realize
howard stern this how
scared he was he stayed in his house did
his show from his house refuse to drive
into manhattan
no one's listening to a show so he goes
we have no time for idiots in this
country anymore we don't want you we uh
we want you all either go the hospital
or stay home die there with your covid
this guy oh
take that cure but don't take him out
but don't close our hospital with your
covid when you finally get it stay home
don't bother with science it's too late
go [ __ ] yourself we just don't have time
for you
um we have it so again this country
people forget about disease it was
always it always wasn't like this you
don't get to live to be 80 years old
automatically it's known science the
reason we lived for lunch because
science
um i really i'm really out of mind to
say look if you didn't get vaccinated
you got code you don't get get in the
hospital you had the cure and you
wouldn't take it
he thinks vaccine is the cure but there
i mean there's people vaccinated it's
not a cure dum dum it's not a cure
you're more likely to get it if you get
the better so there is one thing no no
that's not true that's absolutely not
true but but um so there's like
everything i've read said you're more
likely to get it if you get the vaccine
no it's not telling about it yeah that's
absolutely not true here's the thing so
so it is so the people in the icu beds
and the people that dying right now
statistically are people who didn't get
vaccinated you can look at all the data
that is that is a fact so i so i i think
the argument becomes
your taxpayers still have to pay for you
when you don't have insurance and you're
in there and you're now here's the thing
in my opinion also if you
i i believe in maximum personal freedom
and if you take the vaccine you're
protected uh you can still get covered
you can still carry it you can still you
still pass very rarely you still pass
apparently you can still pass it so if
you want to get the vaccine right if you
want to get the vaccine get the vaccine
and and i that's what i think but the
problem with man making it mandatory is
you have to show proof on your phone
now you can be tracked now it's a
vaccine passport and so
it's a very difficult dicey situation it
is
so some people say well that's okay when
it comes to public health probably i am
a pro-vaccine i get it but i also
improve freedom and i do think we're in
a very dangerous slippery slope how much
freedom did we lose over this war on
terror where everywhere you go and you
know this from your recent experience
everywhere you go you're on video oh
yeah everywhere you go you're on video
that's fine until the wrong people get
in power and start using that against
you that's always been historically the
problem but but also and i have no idea
the statistics but rogan had covet right
so the antibodies that you build up of
having coveted is better than the
vaccine there
there's a lot of scientists is suggest
that yes there's a lot of science
that that and that's the that's not
political that is what a lot of
scientists are saying for sure
right so we have to be open and honest
also about that because then what
happens if a guy this and howard didn't
think like this because he's a soy boy
what happens if
you got covered and you have the
antibodies so and let's say you got
covered two months ago but you have the
antibodies and then you go into the
hospital for undisclosed reason they
grow you back saying go no and according
to his his theory they turn you away
because you're not vaccinated but i have
the antibodies what are you talking
about dude i'm good but i didn't get
vaccinated because i chose not to and
i'm here for a different reason but i'm
not vaccinating you're gonna turn that
person away well it's america you
[ __ ] do you want better though so so
now you're able to track it on your
phone
so
they can also track if they want it they
can track when you're around somebody
who hasn't been vaccinated so that means
that that could put you so when now
you're traveling overseas and they get
that information on their computer and
they say you've been exposed to somebody
who wasn't vaccinated you can't go on
this trip or you've got to go and get a
negative protest because you might be
carrying anyway so all of a sudden all
of a sudden you being around
you being around somebody who's not
vaccinated is a liability it could even
in fact it can even affect whether or
not you get to stay at a certain private
hotel maybe rent a place for a month
maybe an airbnb
these this is how you you start
developing this idea of social credit
score this is what's happening in china
in china you're always tracked with
facial recognition technology that is
here now and the question is how much of
your freedom do you want to lose in the
name of public safety that is a question
yeah dude how much how about arnold said
[ __ ] your freedom
like holy [ __ ] dude yeah it's it's a
really interesting debate here in this
country with my feeling always goes back
to the fact that if i believe in
vaccines i believe in science and i i'm
going to do it but me too but if you but
um
but if i'm vaccinated and you're not
that's on youtube do your thing that's
what i say do your thing i don't give a
[ __ ] do your thing man that was your
decision i don't care i'm back then i'm
taking care of myself and if i get
covered i'll be less likely to die
and if you get coven odds are you're
gonna be okay too but if you end up
worse off that's you man that's on your
same way about lockdowns my daughter for
all you [ __ ] people you know my
daughter was alone in her room
learning school virtually at 12 years
old in her room right okay so [ __ ] you
what what what instead of lockdowns
i would have loved to have seen us say
okay we know that this virus does
discriminate it does discriminate
discriminates against people who are
very overweight uh and old people
underlying health conditions all those
people are worthy of protecting and and
i don't want any sweden did that right
so what you do is you go if you're in a
high risk category you need to stay home
and let's figure this out until we get a
vaccination maybe don't go around don't
shut down everybody's [ __ ] business
my problem was health bureaucrats who
have nothing to lose and don't pay any
price for being wrong shut down people's
businesses that they took 30 years to
build and unless you've done that unless
you've been an entrepreneur unless you
have a business and you rely on that
stuff in a marketplace you don't
appreciate what it is and you have no
idea what they've lost so i don't like
when people who don't pay a price for
being wrong and don't pay a price for
policy make policy i got a problem with
that and all of us should that's not
good that's what we're dealing with man
police howard stern's in the headlines
again
who listen name the line
500 million dollars i don't really want
to i don't know i'm not trying to hear
from you stay in your castle and shout
out people yeah and you stayed home
because you could your show's a shell of
itself what are you talking about dude
and yeah you stay home in your castle
and preach from there what are you
talking about dude what are you talking
about in a way it's like you don't
really live in the real world no god no
he paints and
talks to the therapist and then it shows
a complete [ __ ] show
there you go when's the last time you've
been in yourself it was like you hear
that howard stern no ever
since he went to school he's never
really listened he's never once you're
serious he's on seriously i don't even
have rental cars and they count them as
subscribers sir only
that when you buy a new car you get a
rental car that's the only time that's
the only time when you get a rent car
like oh [ __ ] they're serious i guess
i'll try it out
but when it would whenever it seemed
relevant
and work out did it no who who listens
to serious i have [ __ ] spotify on
itunes for god's sakes where'd he get
serious i can pick the music i want to
listen at any time
you listen to serious yeah there's a
punk station on there all right there's
one fox station dude yeah listen
you have a serious description yeah yeah
i have a subscription in your car yeah
that came with it
no i i came with it but then yeah but
then i purchased
[Applause]
what else would they do
no one's like venturing out to find
[ __ ] serious yeah it's dinosaur land
yeah it's really interesting
i've been in that office i've been in
that place oh yeah i've been there a
bunch of times yeah it's culver city
right there's one down here and there's
one in new york too there's one here
though too that's it's stupid oh no wait
it's right in hollywood yeah there's one
and there's one here the one that i've
been a bunch
he ain't [ __ ] what else you got jen
alrighty
so a conservative group
filed an ethics complaint over aoc's
dress
you know what's a great one you've been
accepted the designer there the dime
piece
i don't know so the designer that dress
who right tax the rich oh you came out
and found out that she has tax liens
against her in four states how great is
it come on that's not true yeah is that
true yeah yeah yeah
uh
behind
there's a history of not paying taxes
yeah how great it is everything was
wrong with this and then aoc who went
there you know it was something like 25
dollars a plate oh yeah thirty five
thirty how hilarious is that she didn't
have to pay to get in did she oh yeah
yeah well
she didn't usually somebody buys the
table and then for her yeah the great
american story is that you can you can
make a lot of money being
anti-establishment
you're still caught up in the capitalist
system yeah yeah so their complaint is
they want to know where the funds came
from you know i mean because you know
the she gets donations from
for her cause right for
what she does so they want to make sure
where that actual the money came from
and it's not right by the uh donation
she's part of the money-making machine
she makes a [ __ ] load of money she makes
a fortune as a speaker oh she does oh
bro when she's done she'll make sure she
makes all the money why she's so loud
about texts she's beautiful she's
[ __ ] so smart she's crazy i find her
very exactly yeah she's very interested
in politics but she's not trying to bat
[ __ ] crazy but i put up with it oh yeah
every morning i'm like yeah [ __ ] tax
the rich [ __ ]
and her points all agree with everything
it's surprising her boyfriend is uh like
a model no take a look at her yeah i bet
he's a soy boy he's a beta male
guarantee it he's just she probably
wakes up and [ __ ] interesting slaps
him in the face
he's uh not what i expected there you go
there you go you're gonna do what you're
told dude yeah you gotta do it you make
the eggs over easy [ __ ] yeah and you're
gonna get it he must be like thank you i
mean he gets that i mean she i guarantee
she looks fantastic
yeah but it's a
nightmare for him
yeah but she's every [ __ ] dude her every
morning oh god it could be a nightmare
yeah somebody global warming every
morning you wanna start your mondays off
with global warming at least he's very
tall he's a big kid
good beard maybe he's a big strong guy i
don't know but i she
yeah he's
yeah what can you do she's a but she's
she's a diamond sexy just bad [ __ ] crazy
she's just she's an ideologue she just
believes in the far left ideology she's
the farthest left
yeah
still so how still how dare you go to
that party without a mask
how dare you yeah
what else you got jen right here
robert durst is convicted of murder oh
god damn time because of the jinx god
about time
did you ever watch the jinx on hbo
remember he gets done he goes of course
i killed this [ __ ] people i killed
all of them he was like i was just
saying that for the show it's like
you're in the bathroom by yourself you
forget you're mic'd up wow so they found
him uh guilty of just one of the murders
right i think so
i'm running his back he got out didn't
he he got out he was oh he's been out
for a grip right yeah but now he's not
now he's [ __ ] he's old as [ __ ] so
basically he got away with it but
it's like when they found that golden
state killer like we've got him you son
of a [ __ ] like dude he's been he's 78
years old yeah he got away with let me
see his face there he just looks he's
just yeah the story's so interesting
like clearly you're murdering these
[ __ ] people dude three people in your
life that you were married to just
disappear right figure it out man
susan was shot in the backhand
back to the head in l.a they were in the
way they were kind of in the way right
she was prepared to tell police how she
helped cover up his wife's killing ooh
baron the daughter of las vegas mobster
durst long time confident who told
friends she provided a phony albie firm
after his wife vanished
such a good a such a good doc
jinx
jinx
okay well he's gonna go i bet he dies
the next two years look at that i mean
he's already could be heard muttering
themselves let me see that
marriage could be hurt i mean in in you
know in a way he's kind of being
imprisoned you know what i'm saying like
you can't go anywhere yeah it's like i
was watching i was watching the o.j
simpson uh trial thing over again
and you know they show jay getting off
in a happy comes back and he you know he
throws this big party and none of his
friends are around he knows friends even
robert kardashian who's his best friend
for 20 years couldn't be around him
because they
they know he killed nicole like they've
seen all the evidence so even robert
kardashian stopped talking to him after
the trial best friend for 20 years his
other friends and he would call in like
his restaurants that he loved in like
brentwood and they're like you can't sit
here dude we don't have a tablespoon and
he was like what like he couldn't
comprehend like no but they said i'm not
guilty like no no we know what they said
but we know what really happened so he's
kind of like grant is not prison where
he's like locked down you're kind of
like your life is pretty over dude
nobody [ __ ] with you none of your
friends all that's all out the window
you're not living the same vibe like you
just can't move the same
you can't go in anywhere without people
like staring at you
where is he now in florida vegas he's in
vegas vegas
plays golf and just kind of hangs out
hello twitter world joe's truly yeah
you're talking about vaccinations like
okay
i mean the comments are just like stab
stabs though
yeah polaris
but you're kind of like you know what
i'm saying like yeah you got off but
your life is tough you're not yeah i bet
you there are people you're not checking
into hotel emma you know what i'm saying
they're like we don't have a room for
you dude yeah yeah i would imagine he's
probably ferrari doesn't want you
driving their cars you know yeah you're
not living the high life you're not
going to those restaurants they don't
want you in the restaurant dude you
murdered two [ __ ] people yeah it's
crazy
um
what did you get jen
this one's for
chappelle
i got one for me yeah your boy liam
gallagher
oh yeah
so what the details are he just fell off
of a helicopter i don't know what the
details are everyone keeps tagging me
but it hasn't said anything like exactly
what happened i just know he just got
done doing playing a concert
and he was catching a helicopter ride
to go back i don't know he toppled out
of a chopper so chicks i fell out of a
helicopter last night you couldn't write
it
uh all good who said rnr is dead keith
moon eat your drum skin out come on you
know lg you know come on come on right
now yeah nice beers are good so he's
just like the drink so he just fell out
of the helicopter yeah like the
helicopter was like chilling that's what
i'm thinking about i went to get out of
here
yeah he's uh
are they still playing and stuff uh he
is uh yeah well yeah both of them are
haven't written any other songs since
the 90s yeah that's two
but they don't they hate each other
right they don't tour together no they
don't tour together they hate each other
yeah they're not they're not good though
right are they they're not good what
makes you say that you're my wonder wow
so
so it's funny you only mentioned two
songs but they have more educate them so
they got two albums they got two they
got no they do not have two albums how
many do they have uh eight uh nine
including a live album they got out nine
out of ten but between the two of them
they they own some b-side albums too
they broke up after two though and then
they no
you don't know what the [ __ ]
yeah you don't you don't know
yeah
i watched their documentary on it
because the supersonic doctors one two
so now how many are that's a [ __ ] ton
like do studio albums some of those are
like b-side albums and yeah you know
[ __ ]
dude remastered don't get that
remastered [ __ ] on my face one two three
four so the last album was dig out your
soul in 2008. but when i was one two
three four four five seven
they broke up seven but see when they
broke up please they broke up in 2009.
he knows he did yeah 2009. his brother
stopped talking in 2009. yeah pretty
much so they played dude
i think i think their last concert was
might have been in italy it was like
august what are you a [ __ ]
oasis fan now dude no but he knows
what's up common sense dude yeah i'm
looking at that i see nine albums okay
when did they get famous when was there
what did they get famous dude
they blew up
off their first record what was that and
then got even bigger
when they came out with morning glory
they really only had two songs all right
no i mean people like yeah come on why
are you doing this
like two songs no
come on
how dare you they but they're not good
ninety-four yes they are no way as a kid
you thought they were good now you're no
no no listen the thing about it always
is is that
it like yesterday you know
they were big everywhere else but the
states yeah you know the states didn't
really appreciate them until like later
later on yeah you know what i mean but
there's i mean why did they break down
you're a musician i mean they did what
do you think i only heard the the main
hits so it's cool
it's cool yeah it's cool yeah that's not
my couple that's that's not what she
listens to
kids though huh it's for kids it's for
like when chapelle was 15.
and now chabelle has an emotional
attachment so he can't let it go but he
knows chappelle's having trouble writing
but i'm having trouble i'm not having
trouble and he's trying to get my mind
how many albums have they sold
oh wow
they're only two morning glory probably
sold the most
yeah i don't care i just want to see
there you go
41 million shut the [ __ ] up right
shut up though shut up seven studio
albums yeah what is the studio album
versus uh what does that mean hey hey
hey check this out this is cool
so oasis has has moved over
58.7
0.7 million album sales this puts them
at the bottom of the top
50 all-time biggest bands
shut the [ __ ] up
do me a favor you know what you're
talking about i'd rather you talk
football zone two defense
whoa
41 million [ __ ] units oh shut the
[ __ ] up dude
why don't you suck
uh liam
75 million worldwide i'm sorry
all right dude go [ __ ] this side of
my guinness world 22 consecutive hits in
the top 10. wait what is that guinness
world record yeah get your [ __ ] most
successful accidents go get front row
seats
go get front row seats
i would you're old huh [ __ ] off man i
don't [ __ ] i i know music dude
dude you should shazam oasis
piece of [ __ ]
that's some albums it's a lot of albums
all right let's change this
great career great one more maddie
pacquiao there are rumors that he's
going to run for president but who
you know what he doesn't need your vote
but here's the thing duterte
is he's a strong man he'll kill him he
they've killed they put to death 25 000
low-level drug dealers man i mean do
they kill anybody i mean you said
low-level drugs yeah he's a he's got a
vigilante yeah he's a monster when he
was a mayor he had he's a murderer he's
a bad guy no so man he's gonna run
against him i'm sure security has to be
pretty increased and is it worth it
manny you do need a nice guy
yeah do you have dual citizenship no no
no no no no
he absolutely does not oh okay no
i like america i wonder how that's gonna
work citizenship
pretty easily or no like would it be
like i don't know process i don't know
is he
he says he's retired ugass is a killer
i feel like since bernard hopkins fought
till he was 50 if anybody could keep
fighting with pacquiao but he's done it
for so long he's probably he's running
for the president of the philippines
yeah and that's the current event
not him boxing
uh another bachelor party earlier
nominated roberta rodrigo duterte i
wouldn't want to run against him because
he'll assassinate that's where i'm at
like his security team have to be
through the [ __ ] roof yeah man
oh he loves his heart
second six-year term has accepted the
nomination jesus christ who has declined
wow because senator accused
his former ally of making corruption
worse than philippines ooh doggies can
get nasty yeah but listen
look at this he's determined his money
goes a long way in the philippines has
been brought up against with the
international criminal court jesus
crimes against humanity yeah it's very
tough and they were shooting people
right in the street yep hopefully man
like just straight up oh dude
like like and then they and then the
problem was they would have
uh vigilante groups so they'd be like we
work for the government and problem is
you got a rival drug gang or you got
whatever dude you're dude you're lucky
to be alive you're lucky you made it out
on your dad's first [ __ ] class jet
how long were you there
oh
don't pay me no dude you're lucky you
made it out of the filipino jungles in
the in your private jet no dude you
don't know maybe i was [ __ ] see you
dirty
you've made the game right
yeah like you made it
thank god man yeah well listen thank god
daddy was like get on the jet we had to
leave all the champagne we had to leave
leave all our bars of gold
oh
man that's a shame
is that it
that's it all right
all righty uh i'm doing uh i'll be in
san antonio saturday saturday bud light
courtyard the big boys saturday san
antonio chappelle lacy derrick poston
and also david lucas the squad is out
that's one show saturday in san antonio
but also before the show saturday i'm
doing a charity event it will be a live
zoom call it's called downtown showdown
to fight kidney disease what you can do
is send questions whatever it is fight
related fashion cars
dad life whatever it is send it to thick
fans that's thick with three c's thick
fans at thickboy.com and your answer or
your questions will get answered on the
live feed i'll have all the swipe up all
the info and that is the downtown
showdown in toronto
to add uh value to the charity event for
fighting kidney disease so saturday san
antonio with the squad and then next
week uh denver colorado if you're
thinking about buying tickets for me
brian just hold your money wait for me
on their next week
this week i'm there next weekend
september 30th october 2nd meet this
mama if you have to pick you know who to
come see mama denver
september 30th october 2nd comedy works
downtown see all my family friends there
don't worry if you don't go to bryan's
uh las vegas nevada uh new wise guys
outside las vegas nevada outside the
strip that's the wise guys new club
october 7th through october 9th for me
in columbus and then break california
october 15th through 17th then i have
some special news for the dallas show
november 11th 13th i'll get more to it
as we get closer that's dallas texas uh
hey mama i'm coming home i'm just
weekend mom you're not going mom aunt
nubby mommy and i'm there no you want to
try and stack them you piece of [ __ ]
listen man we have a thing and i'm not
going to lie to you mom i'll send you
that picture of his balls is disgusting
don't do that to your mom you're not a
woman you're a woman my age and things
are going to get
crazy now listen don't worry about it we
won't tell brendan denver colorado
comedy works downtown september 23 24
25. go to my instagram i did a little
video for it chicago illinois improv
september 30th october 1 and 2. that's
wrong october 1 and 2 and then columbus
ohio funny bone october 8 and 9. get
your tickets briangallon.com or
f-a-t-k-z
dot com chappelle where are you and then
october 7th through the 9th
of florida i'm missing vegas sorry uh
tampa florida side splitters and then
october 28th through the 29th the dc
comedy comedy off to dc in washington
d.c all right kids love you see ya